[Applause]
[Music]
good evening
now get here how are you i'm nervous
that's the really nervous and exciting
to be here absolutely what's the secret
success behind ducan what is it simple
dishes from uh my mum's cooking mm-hmm
zita what's the secret behind your
cooking what is it the good quality
cooking yes and keep your customers
cubby that's what tonight's all about if
you want to make it back to the
semi-finals okay you need to do bloody
well tonight okay because only the top
six
high scores go through to the
semi-finals
this needs to be the best service of
your lives
tonight greek wrestling red cena and
moroccan restaurant ducan will battle
for a place in next week's semi-final
here's why i chose them
the ninth and final category my search
with f word's best local restaurant is
the rest of the world
from japanese to lebanese
from polish to portuguese here in
britain we've got it all
my team and i've been all over britain
checking out your favorite restaurants
if i had this for lunch every day my
backside would be the size of a bus
after months of searching through an
extraordinary array of international
cuisines we whittle down your
nominations to two truly outstanding
restaurants
both serve food from the mediterranean
and i couldn't wait to put them to the
test
the first is ducan in wadsworth south
london
duke and serves classic moroccan food
and the man behind it is hospitality
manager turned owner abdeslam khalil
i've been asked time and time again
whether i could recommend a good
moroccan restaurant in in london i
genuinely couldn't and i opened my own
duken opened a year ago and is a hit
with the locals
everything i've ever chosen off the menu
has been just delicious
[Music]
kellie left casablanca 20 years ago to
study hotel management in london but as
he's yearning to cook grew he started to
teach himself in his spare time
i am not a trained chef i am self-taught
when i make dishes i don't look at a
book i just think of the core
ingredients and i keep on tweaking them
until it reaches all those senses that
are important for you to taste service
f word viewers had nothing but praise
for khalil's food so i decided to pay
duke and a visit
hello sir come this way please come
through excellent good to see you tell
me the success behind the restaurants
well i actually do it's just passion for
moroccan cuisine i just cooked because
my mother cooked beautifully right i
grew up in a household where having
lunch was like the most important thing
that happens i'm glad that you're so
passionate the fact that it has to be
authentic passionate guy very passionate
i want a quaint little place
from the outside it looks like a little
cafe bar walk inside and there's a
little mini oasis nice
to kick off my moroccan feast khalil
brings me a lamb's liver train the way
my mom used to make lamb's liver oh
lovely and so the liver has been sauteed
that's right they've been actually
cooked twice very gently thank you very
indeed
yeah the chopped lamb liver is delicious
i mean authentic started with cumin and
he cooked them twice very very quickly
chop them and then quickly again so for
a guy that's self-trained uh he
definitely knows how to cook next up is
chicken breast stuffed with figs and
almonds with spiced couscous
in terms of couscous do you steam that
or is it yeah it's steamed a lot of
people ask me how do you get your
couscous right and it's really the
simplest thing you can do just you don't
leave it alone you need to give it a
little bit of love and attention
oh my god that's lovely
really good chicken stuffed with figs
with an apricot sauce sounds very very
sweet but he's managed to get the
balance absolutely spot on
if we win the competition it'll mean so
much to me it's like the underdog
winning the race great lunch yeah really
enjoyed it um it's been a tough decision
i can only put two rations through to
cooking the f word kitchen
and duken
is one of them congratulations thank you
very much absolutely really good thank
you and i'm very very happy absolutely
delicious you kept that authenticity and
that's really important for a local
eatery thank you very much you actually
filled my heart with joy we went through
thanks a lot cheers for going through
here
fraschetta's not even professionally
trained he's certainly been listening to
his mother that's for sure
i think my mother would be proud
the other ration i've chosen from your
nominations in the rest of the world
category is in belsize park north london
retsina is a traditional family-run
greek restaurant
since his father retired 13 years ago
son minos has been managing the business
cena's our family business it's been
going on for around 25 years so it's our
life in one way or another
minos's mother zita has been cooking for
over 50 years but still refuses to hang
up her apron i like to be in the kitchen
i join to be in the kitchen and make me
really please
what makes my mom a great chef she's a
perfectionist you know she was brought
up with greek food and she knows what
greek food is all about
zeta's delicious greek recipes keep
redzina's customers coming back for more
the food is absolutely fantastic you
know
you just feel like the quality of it is
brilliant
i've been to quite a few greek
restaurants before but this one's
definitely the best restaurant without a
doubt
f word viewers gave ritzina such glowing
testimonials i decided to go there for
lunch myself
hello
hi there how are you minos nice to meet
you meet up good to see you smells
amazing and where's the chef how are you
i'm very well thank you
nice to see you
you look beautiful now what's for lunch
today what have you got as a special in
the oven we have the souvla
kebabs rice
roast potatoes okay brilliant well i'll
leave it to you
after zeta's lovely warm welcome i
already felt at home but would the food
live up to his reputation
first up classic greek meze calamari
octopus and a selection of dips nice and
how the octopus cooked and squirted
grilled really does smell amazing
you can really balls up
cooking octopus but that's done
beautifully
so far cedar's cooking was seriously
good i couldn't wait to get it stuck
into my main course
shoulder of lamb beef stefado roast
potatoes and lamb and chicken spit roast
the dishes kept on coming
delicious i mean really good that
shoulder of lamb i mean that's the cut
that a lot of chefs don't understand how
to cook she does there should be a lot
more chefs in london coming to spend a
day with this lady here to see how to
braise yeah a shoulder of lamb
it will be very honor for us we're going
to be over the moon to win it
the problem
i'm faced with is the variety of
restaurants
so the unfortunate news is and i'm
really sorry to say this because i know
you don't like taking any time out but
you're through congratulations
congratulations and it tasted fantastic
um
really congratulations
authentic and delicious
so now you have to take another day off
okay
if you couldn't spot the chef you'd want
to meet the person because you can't
quite believe that that level of
authenticity is there so
it's just the most amazing great food
i'm very pleased
and i will try my best to keep those 50
customers happy
so from your nominations i've chosen two
extraordinary restaurants
[Music]
while the f-word diners prefer the
traditional moroccan dishes khalil
creates for his beloved restaurant ducan
or mamazita's home cooking at the greek
restaurant retsina we're back in london
at the f word restaurants
we're going global in our rest of the
world category to celebrate local
restaurants serving as delicious food
from all four corners of the earth
and thanks to your nominations and
months of searching we've found two
exceptional restaurants
greet red cena in north london and
moroccan dukkhan in south london
sardines are very popular in both
morocco and greece so i've challenged
the brigades to cook their starters with
this delicious mediterranean fish
guys it's not a race okay tonight is
about that level of excitement
consistency and make sure
you're happy with everything you send
at dukkhan in south london khalil's love
for food stems from his moroccan
childhood i've always kind of embraced
food i was surrounded with food due to
the mother that is very very passionate
about cuisine before he started tonight
khalil is making sardine fritters
he mixes sliced sardines with shallots
cumin lemon thyme rolls them into balls
and fries them until golden
he serves with bulgur wheat and tomato
and a green pepper dressing so killer
you've gone for modern interpretation
with this round sardine dish
the idea was actually to make a meatball
without actually being a really immense
sardine because they go dark and
horrible when you do that the idea came
from where it's it's the way we've
always done them i mean my mom used
fried them she didn't fry them in bowls
necessarily she did them
butterflied with some flour and some
molar she was a big influence on your
cooking oh very much so i mean the only
influence really nazita on new year's
eve are you going to put your feet up
and say no more cooking i'm not quick he
wants to eat yeah i'm not cooking new
year's day is your night off yes so
that's the only day
tucked away in the suburbs of north
london israel cena a restaurant that
serves classic greek food in a warm
friendly atmosphere
i've been coming here for 20 years it's
got to say something for the restaurant
and the people
brittsina's food is all about simplicity
so tonight they're cooking grilled
sardines with greek tomato sauce
they glaze their sardines in olive oil
and sprinkle with oregano then grill
them on both sides and serve with salad
and a greek tomato sauce made with
chopped tomatoes garlic coriander cumin
and paprika
you're cooking the sardines on the grill
yes on the bone and the bone so you're
convinced that your sardine yes grilled
plainly on the bone is going to be far
tastier than ducans yes yes why you have
to have the bone to give more taste okay
interesting and why do you think yours
without the bone is going to taste
better than zetas i think zita is wrong
because i've got a few bits of bones in
there just to keep the flavour
you've missed your boat i'm kidding i
made sure the little balls in the sun
are there eating sardines you can accept
a few bones everywhere exactly
unless you're the queen mother i feel i
feel a fight coming here from zita
zeta frame zina takes the food very
seriously but for some greeks it's
almost a religion
traditional home-cooked food is sacred
to greeks
and there's a group of keen greek cooks
who are about to put my skills to the
test
i've been given the ultimate challenge
to create an amazing dish for a
fantastic greek cookbook
whether or not my recipe makes the grade
will be down to this group the
congregation from a greek orthodox
church in north london
they're so passionate about greek food
that they're putting together their own
cookbook
for the creeks and cypress food is it is
very important is the most important
thing is their lives so we decided just
to make a book and then sell it just to
raise some money for the church as well
nikki rossu andreyu has collected dozens
of traditional greek recipes to ensure
they're preserved for future generations
of london greeks and only the best will
go in her book if golden recipes is is
good enough he's going to just put in
the book otherwise it's not
i love a challenge but in order to
succeed i need to create a fantastic
dish using a classic greek ingredient
i've chosen one that's doubled in
popularity in britain over the past 10
years halloumi cheese and i'll be making
it from scratch
now i'm taking a bit of risk here
because we're also used to eating
halloumi cheese made out of cow's milk
i'm gonna push the boat out and make
mine with a hundred percent sheep's milk
today's cow's milk is used in
mass-produced halloumi because it's
cheaper
but traditionally greek cypriots use
sheep or goat's milk because it provides
a richer flavor i want the very best so
i'll be doing the same with the help of
dairy farmer kylie threadgold
so why is it that we're not actually
sort of eating and drinking more sheep's
milk a lot of people don't actually
associate sheep with milk no if you
think of uh famous french cheeses we've
got rock for it's an unpasteurized
sheep's milk cheese yeah that's not a
very big teat is it no that's what i say
it is a finger and thumb job really
either jesus
the fat content in sheep's milk will
make my halloumi creamier and softer
than cheese made with cow's milk
i tell you what you make it looks so
easy yeah there's an art to it isn't
there
i think she's just about empty there
gordon you sell that unpasteurized we do
sell added pasteurized obviously we
produce it normally in a nice clean
milking parlor
it's so creamy it is incredibly creamy
that looks fantastic you know that it
does really good thick rich creamy and
about to be turned into the most amazing
halloumi
that's harder than i thought it was
gonna be thank you well done with a
churn full of the freshest cheeks milk i
leave essex and head to west sussex to
meet one of the only halloumi cheese
makers in the uk
mark hardy produces halloumi using
nothing but sheep's milk and i'm relying
on his expertise to teach me to make the
very best
this is halloumi we made about three
days ago i'm dying to taste it
nice creakiness to it smells lovely got
really good flavor
as it breaks down the mouth there's more
creamy beauty season all the way in
which is lovely really nice and deep so
that's the objective for mine to come
out as good as this one it is i'm sure
it will
my halloumi will be made using the most
traditional greek cypriot methods never
made it before always been fascinated by
its texture bring the milk up to 32
degrees an enzyme is added called rennet
and in 30 minutes it sets the milk so it
can be split into curds and whey
and the curd here that's basically this
sort of
that's the foundation for cheese it's
where the cheese will come from as the
curds and whey are warmed the
consistency constantly changes it's like
scrambled egg now it does look less
carbohydrate doesn't it
the curd is then pressed into a mold and
left to cool
the lumi is simmered in the way for 45
minutes and is this process that stops
it melting like other cheeses when you
cook it
so now they're floating
and that's it yep still quite soft
aren't they when you lift it out it
should bounce back right basically which
is what it's doing
to preserve the cheese and give the
halloumi it's salty flavor it's dropped
into brine for 24 hours
then it'll be dressed with mint to
enhance its flavor
now i've got to think of something
really exciting to do it justice
yeah
i have a recipe in mind that will
complement the slightly salty flavor of
my handmade halloumi but would it be
good enough for nikki's all-greek
cookbook
hi how are you i'm okay good about you
very wondering thank you very happy to
be here now that looks amazing oh that's
good yes okay thank you nikki has sent
me the challenge of coming up with a
recipe that can sit alongside these
truly authentic greek dishes
right i've got work cut out big time and
all i've got is this amazing halloumi
handmade so i'm gonna do salad and pan
fried scallops with some wonderful
sauteed 100 sheep's milk halloumi
slice the scallops and coat them in
flour egg and japanese breadcrumbs get
them nice and crisp on the outside
and very sort of sweet
in the middle their sweet flavor will go
brilliantly with a salty halloumi the
good thing about halloumi made with a
hundred percent sheep's milk is it
doesn't crumble now
discs of halloumi to sit on top of the
roasted scallops hot pan the halloumi is
fried alongside the scallops in olive
oil nice thing about the lumi when you
saute it like that it doesn't melt it
doesn't disintegrate but what it does do
is get a really nice flavor a little
seasoning on the scallops
to go with the halloumi and scallops a
caper and sultana vinaigrette
simply boil both in some salted water a
little touch
of olive oil in there and a teaspoon
of white wine vinegar
then blitz scallops onto the plate
the golden brown halloumi is then served
on the scallops with the vinaigrette
that
looks amazing
i hope i've done justice to my halloumi
and more importantly it passes the test
for their authentic greek cookbook
all right
please take a little slice okay
you like that it's delicious really
no
first and foremost important how was the
halloumi first very good halloween it's
like the halloumi that you are making at
home and it's very very nice really and
the combination with that and the
discoloration is brilliant really it's
very good the most important question is
it going to go in the cookbook oh yes
yes
excellent thank you yes please we wish
you all the best thank you very much
indeed
very nice last table is a two okay a
little wipe down
four last table yes little wipe down
first so don't go up and leave the
plates good well done that's your last
table yes yes yes clear down and get
ready for the main course well done
it was very tasty and the sauce was very
complimentary to the fish once you
actually
managed to get it off of the bone nice
to see you both are you well yeah very
well it's good to see you again
good to see you too
what would it mean for you tonight to
walk out here as a winner oh it'll be
absolutely fantastic especially for my
mother all the years that she's worked
in the kitchens and one more another it
would be fantastic
extraordinary woman that is so
passionate hasn't taken the whole day in
two years where is he going to retire
i've been doing that for years the
reason i bought this big restaurant
overall so to calm down a bit relax a
bit well you could do a deal with her
promise her to shave
properly and then she could retire no
maybe maybe maybe yes i would have gone
in yes you should have saved it for it
um good to see you guys thank you take
care bye-bye
it didn't have much taste and to be
honest when you see a sardine you expect
it to be like a sardine nice and fresh
and grilled not messed around like that
isabella nice to see you nice to see you
hi wise welcome to the f word how are
you very excited yeah watching it in
action how does it make you feel well
he's not normally like that he's a bit
stressed today but uh i'm sure he's
enjoying himself yeah do you think he's
gonna win tonight well i really hope so
because he's he's so passionate and he
really cooks with his heart so yeah nice
to see you hope you enjoyed my courses
thank you thank you
right redzina's simply grilled sardine
hopefully they'll just flake off the
bone nicely
yeah beautiful
touch of the sauce
flavor delicious seasoned beautifully
and it just falls away from the bone
delicious really good now do can it
looks like a plate of meatballs on
couscous
he's left the skin on which is a bit
disturbing
does it deliver in flavor
quite mushy and floury inside
and it doesn't actually taste much of a
sardine it's a clear winner for me
definitely it's seen as char grilled
sardine simply done tasting delicious no
fuss
if the donors don't like their starters
they don't pay the results are in thank
you
so duke let's start off with you first
yes
the number of customers
that are happy to pay
for their starter out of 25
is
[Music]
congratulations 21 out of 25
great start what are they like debbie
um great presentation great presentation
clearly and a great zesty sauce has one
21 out of 25 great start
really well done yes
okay
retina the number of customers that are
happy to pay
for your sardine out of 25 is
[Music]
23 out of 25. well done
that's incredible
that
is a great start thank you for everybody
what are they like they thought that the
the fish had a great smoky flavor and
the sauce complement very well the fish
as well thank you to everybody thank you
two very very good starts 21 out of 25
23 out of 25 there's only two points in
it and there's 50 main courses each
great start clear down yeah let's
concentrate on the main course now both
thresholds are going to cook their main
course first up ducan
duken's signature dish tonight is king
prawn and muscle tagine i'll take a
couple of peppers from there
khalil starts by making sharmulla paste
with chopped coriander sliced garlic
salt cumin paprika and lemon juice
he adds finely chopped preserved lemons
and mixes with olive oil to make a paste
he puts the shamula into a sizzling pan
two generous teaspoons there and adds
king prawns and harissa
it's beautiful smell really really
beautiful
the adds chopped roasted red peppers
mussels and covers
really mostly what i'm trying to get
there is the flavor and the color for
the dish
then add sliced potatoes and simmers
he serves in a tagine pot and garnishes
with grilled lemon and coriander
king prawn and mussel tagine
served
what's so special about this tagine it's
made with charmoula a very well known
moroccan marinade and how successful is
this tajin with the prawns and mussels
been in the restaurant this is very
successful actually i mean i've got
people coming particularly just for this
dish yeah so cetera where did you learn
to cook i learned from a very young age
i like to be in the kitchen with my
mother
at greek restaurant rosina head chef
zita's menu is inspired by recipes she
learned from her mother
retzina's signature dish tonight is a
greek mixed grill
for the chicken kebabs is either cubes a
chicken breast she then coats the
chicken with a marinade of oregano greek
yogurt pepper puree crushed garlic lemon
juice and olive oil
i make a taste and moist not to get dry
because always the breast the chicken if
you're not very careful it's very dry
for the lamb kebabs zita marinades cubes
of lamb in pepper puree lemon juice and
oregano next she chops onion and tomato
for the kebabs then grails
and base with olive oil and lemon juice
oregano salt and pepper
then she grills the lamb cutlets
and finally ceta grills the cards liver
then plates everything up with fresh
tasiki tabouleh some rocket leaves and a
wedge of lemon
fredzina's greek mixed grill served
[Music]
why do you think the diners will be
excited about this it's very juicy very
tasty
very nice now your son said that if you
win tonight he's going to shave
yes that stupid beard off i've got a
sharp knife oh my god
if you win tonight it's coming off
that's the game
good news for his lively studio we have
to do it definitely guys remember yeah
every table has to go out like the first
level yeah with that level of exact
perfection yeah absolutely good
now for some festive pie filling
moroccan style
traditional british mince pies have been
around for centuries
they used to be filled with fruit real
mince meat and spices brought back from
the middle east during the crusades
over time the meat has given way to the
fruit and spices
they still do something similar in
morocco but it's called pastilla
but moroccans use a meat seldom seen on
british menus pigeon
[Music]
who better to send on a taste test than
my favorite old london bird janet street
porter
most people think of pigeons as nasty
bourbon and wouldn't dream of eating
them it's not surprising is it the
scruffy feral pigeons we see in our
cities hardly look appetizing i wouldn't
even think about eating them pigeons are
surrounded okay so flying rats don't
exactly get you going
but wood pigeon the feral pigeons clean
living country cousin might in morocco
they absolutely love it
now i love moroccan food and i think
they've got exactly the right idea when
it comes to making pigeons tasty
wood pigeon is on the menu of one of the
finest moroccan restaurants in the uk
momo in central london i'm here to meet
executive chef mohammed aurad
hi mohammed i'm janet wood pigeon is
prized for its rich red meat but you'll
probably need to order it from your
local butcher okay so they're not
skunking not flowing right they're not
flying rats that's very good they're not
blind rats that is a free-range wood
pigeon it looks absolutely delicious
mohammed's going to be showing me a
classic moroccan dish that you can do at
home pastillas with a pigeon filling
tell me what it is it's a pie it's a pie
with this very complicated p filo pastry
exactly
first the filling mohammed fries finely
diced onions in butter how many of these
do you make in a week you make about 30
days 30 a day next we take the breast
meat off the bone and add the carcasses
to the onions moroccan cuisine is all
about spices scents and colors so we
also add chopped coriander and sliced
ginger five sticks of cinnamon in bosch
for squash and a pinch of saffron
now leave this to food
two hours at least
okay great the pigeon breasts are coated
in olive oil seasoned and seared in a
separate pan we remove the carcasses and
cinnamon sticks and add sugar it smells
delicious sugar helps to create that
mouth-watering moroccan mix of sweet and
savory flavors that reminds me of
christmas
as the filling mixture reduces we dice
the pigeon breast
two beaten eggs are added to thicken and
bind the filling mix we add an extra
sprinkle of cinnamon and the pigeon meat
goes in it's an unusual combination of
smells it's very very unusual the
pastilla filling is now ready now final
stitch brush the edge of a sheet of
phyllo pastry with egg white place the
pigeon meat filling in the center and
top with roast almonds fold the pastry
so it's a very
sophisticated piece of origami wrap a
second sheet around the pastilla and
stick down with egg whites all right
i'll have a go okay i go in yeah try to
no no no no no no
don't worry i'm on it i'm on it okay i
think what i really like about moroccan
food is combining meat with sweet things
it's just fantastic
look at that
we glaze the pastilles with butter and
stick them in a hot oven for five
minutes
oh it looked fantastic
that's my one
and that's your one
finally we dust them with icing sugar
and finish with cinnamon
truly moorish
it's delicious
it is it's a combination of sugar and
meat together right i'm going to take
mine for gordon
right it wasn't nice having you it's a
good life thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're great thank you now moroccan
restaurant in the house tonight yes
you've also been cooking a spot of
moroccan cuisine today i learned how to
cook a pasta
amazing so this is pigeon yes dear this
is something that i've eaten in morocco
it's meat sugar and eggs together that's
delicious in filo pastry but it's
delicious really good indeed now they're
not the sort of average pigeon that fly
over nelson's column these are wood
pigeons they're wood pigeons and they're
very plump when you cook pigeon it
overcooks within seconds that is moist
delicious slightly gamey but sweet what
you are supposed to say golden rice if
you don't mind me please saying so
janet what a beautiful pie you made with
that filo pastry
folding it round your meat no you just
mashed it up beforehand it was it was
like origami really well done good to
see you
last table
for stunning grill yes
make him perfect guys yeah well done
thank you very good thank you thank you
really well done well everybody yeah job
well done thank you
the meat was all cooked to perfection um
i thought it went really well with the
satsiki
and the tabouli it was really nice
actually
the only thing that led it down was the
prawns they were slightly overdone but
the presentation was fantastic lifting
off the lid was really good right i've
been dying to taste these and
bed scenes grill
lamb
nicely marked beautifully cooked
and
that's delicious
again simply done
beautifully char grilled chicken
marinated with the pepper and the onions
yeah i mean the whole thing looks simple
but the most important thing about this
is getting every little component right
and they have
duken
uh
awkward
muscles in the shout prawns with the
heads on and then potato in the bottom
so
prawns slightly rubbery it's a great
shame
and when they're bright white like that
inside it's it's a sign of the prawn
actually being so overcooked
potato at the bottom
that's really weird
because potatoes rock hard
overcooked prawn and a slightly
undercooked potato what a shame i hope
the diners didn't get what i got
so it was up to me definitely the mixed
drill
the votes have been counted and the
results are in right
results of the main course jb
please
good luck to all four of you uh right uh
zita
so
the number of customers that happy to
pay for your mixed grill out of 50
is
[Music]
well done 37 out of 50. ah really good
thank you
for the like
and before the the meat was delicious
yes and the tizzaki was full of flavor
and the third thing they didn't pay what
are they saying
the liver of the cooked and the veg
undercooked and the veg on the skewer
undercooked yeah okay
right
the number of customers they're happy to
pay out of 50 for your tagine
[Music]
is
[Music]
19 out of 50.
what went wrong
um
prawns overcooked the potato undercooked
that's the kick in the balls you can
pull this back do not give up okay
thanks jeff yeah the diners are sitting
in judgment on two brigades who are
determined to make it through to next
week's semi-finals
and if they make it all the way to the
grand final they'll be cooking with meat
provided by janet from her farm in
yorkshire
this series i've asked janet to provide
the meat for the f word's best local
restaurant competition final come out
your bloody lazy birds get off your
asses
along the way she picked up a few prizes
of her own
both her dexter cattle and a mangalits
of pigs won rosetta at the prestigious
nidadell show
oh my word janet well don't
oh fantastic
a sure sign of the quality we can expect
in the f-word kitchen
janet's dexter stairs and ixworth
poultry have already gone for slaughter
but the three porkers have clearly got
under her skin and janet's face with the
hardest farewell of all
hi guys i've come to say goodbye
i'm afraid it's
off to the slaughterhouse for you
i'm sorry
because you've been good fun
and you've got great personalities
but you're gonna make the most fantastic
me i know that
do you want one last game of football
should we just have one last game
i'll be in goal
come on pass
pass it
come on pass
they will make the most brilliant me i
know that and they've really fattened up
well
they're really happy animals
so i don't feel that bad about them
going to the slaughter
yeah right very good
janet takes the pigs on their final
journey
well i'm sad the pigs are going to be
saluted because they of all the animals
they've got
the biggest personalities and they've
been a real pleasure to be around on the
other hand they're never going to be
pets they will always be in bread for
food and i think they've had a terrific
life
hello janet hi martin oh terrible
weather beautiful weather
slaughter man martin mcintyre leads the
pigs to a temporary pen
this brief respite allows the pigs to
relax and it's called larige nice piece
i don't want the last time they see me
to be wearing looking like this
the pigs will be slaughtered as humanely
as possible so before they are killed
they'll be stunned
electrical tongs past 240 volts through
the pig knocking it out they'll know and
feel nothing
the pig's throat must be cut within 15
seconds of stunning to ensure an
absolutely painless end
i mean it's hard to watch
you sure they don't feel anything not a
thing
the pig now dead its carcass goes into
hot water tank to get rid of its
extraordinary wiry hair
feel that janet
like a baby's bone
[Applause]
an inspector from the meat hygiene
service monitors the slaughter process
to make sure all the meat and offal is
fit for human consumption
the pig is then gutted and his organs
inspected
so does the meat inspector inspect all
of this
yeah
they have to be certified before they
can pass into the food supply chain
next she inspects the carcass
i think that's really good yeah it's a
good pig good pig right so we can serve
that in golden's restaurant yeah you can
okay well get your stamp on it then
finally the carcass is split and hung in
the chiller ready for shipping
pork should hang for two to three days
for its best flavor
back at her small holding janet has time
to reflect on a in a lifetime farming
experience
mother room well it's not something i
took to
i miss the pigs
eggs worth chickens dexter cattle
mangalits of pigs the two restaurants
lucky enough to go through to next
week's final are sure to have some
fantastic meat to cook with
[Music]
for the dessert the brigades are cooking
my recipe for apple cake which is
inspired by the sweet and spicy flavors
of morocco and grease
spiced apple cake aromatic sweet and
really easy to make first off start
preparing the apples
hot pan butter
apples
chop
cinnamon powder
honey
that starts to get the apples really
nice and caramelized
then add dates
orange zest
and spoon into baking dishes
for the sponge topping sift 125 grams of
plain flour add a pinch of salt
castor sugar
baking powder
butter
and blitz
and what you're looking for is this
really nice soft bread crumb texture
then add orange zest and mix in beaten
egg
milk and vanilla extract
spoon onto the spiced apples
sprinkle with flaked almonds
and bake for around 18 minutes
[Applause]
dust with icing sugar and finish with
vanilla ice cream
spiced apple cake
done
so i want all these desserts to be
absolutely
perfect yes this is my recipe and
there's no excuse on this one yeah
the cigarettes in the caramelization of
the apples yes add the dates
season the cinnamon glaze with the honey
yes okay do you wish you were grilling
the apples on the grill or you're happy
that we knew this in a pan
yeah
let's go guys ice cream's melting let's
go we should be melting in front of the
customer wait yeah not in front of us
tonight i'm going up against colt fleet
star faye ripley
if she loses the challenge tonight she
promises to eat this little baby here
a plate of cold feet yo i'm gonna have
to win aren't you you definitely have to
win
now what are you cooking brownies we're
gonna do my break your diet brownies uh
you're cooking brownies yeah so i'm
gonna make my favorite recipe chocolate
brownies confident i'm aware of the fact
that i don't have any michelin stars
if i beat you yes it would be the
greatest achievement of my life i'm
going to include the birth of my two
children
is that wrong
i feel very honored to hear that now is
that slow-motion whisk in there what is
that my sugar and my eggs this is enough
i don't need to show off my equipment
i'm just this is very much back to
basics over here in a minute when that's
cooled down i'm gonna just combine that
just fold that in there what are you
doing okay in here my memory i've got my
butter and my chocolate melting nice and
slowly yes okay and then
eggs
vanilla sugar in i'm gonna go for some
electricity so excuse me why i have a
quick whisk go on um now you were 30
when you got your big break on cold feet
grip the nation yes and quite moving as
well quite emotional it had a massive
effect on my career and my life that
show it had a good old combo didn't it
people still sort of very nostalgic
about it and they're sweet you know
people still talk about it to me in the
streets and stuff now your husband's
australian yeah yes and he's a lot
younger than you does that make you a
cougar
he's not that much younger than me four
years in men's terms is yeah it's my
wife thinks he's quite hot he is quite
honest yes yes your husband did a an
amazing naked scene in mural's wedding
yes
my husband gets to often be naked on the
screen do you know he had his lips
around emmanuel bayard's nipple once he
was it's just what you do notice when
you go to work
you suck someone's nipple it's what you
have to do he gets to have sex on screen
with loads of really beautiful women i
get john thompson jesus christ would you
ever do a naked scene i don't think
anyone would want to see it to be honest
no one's going to pay money perhaps in a
light comedy they might now you're
copying me because everything i do okay
from adding
me what do you mean i'm copying you stop
copying my wrist stop copying my wrist
it's embarrassing
now melted the chocolate with the butter
over bain marie and then folded in the
cocoa powder and the flour and then
broke through
these really nice little lumps of milk
chocolate dark chocolate and white
chocolate throughout the mix quite dense
so it's going to melt and cook at the
same time
tree spoon paper at the bottom yeah stop
it from sticking
and then straight in yeah
time to find out what the blind tasers
make of the brownies let's plate up look
at that baby
whatever okay let's go side by side
because that's really good right
where is he my little french fighter
pilot off you go stick with me kid don't
forget i pay your salary let's go
but i might do one day
it's very crumbly isn't it it's very
very light
very dry but quite nice quite dry it's
too sticky it's not sweet and bitter
which is nice
okay it's caramelised almost this one's
like a little bit sweeter as well which
i quite like
the texture holds up better must be on
the outside then soft in the middle
right quite the confident
no
you are right jp results oh no he's got
that smoke on his face i don't like it
right how did they go down you won very
well what was the score first um
four to one four to one
four one to who
am i done oh no
come on i'm gonna punch the air oh come
on
you're joking aren't you 4-1 yeah so the
michelin stars look why didn't they like
mine um it wasn't cooked enough wasn't
cooked enough yeah it was undercooked
mine was perfect soft and gooey in the
center crisp on the outside
actually too gooey yeah four ones i
can't believe you beat me one four one
i'll send you the recipe bye babes thank
you thanks
there
with a place in the semi-finals at stake
everything rests on this last course
come on you can pull this back yes yes
now it's about
reputation restaurant what you stand for
what you believe in yeah and what you
decide to open that restaurant
absolutely okay absolutely don't let one
dish yeah put you off yes it's a kick in
the bollocks clearly however you can
pull it back yeah thank your chef yeah
and cetera
yeah yeah it's not over so the fat lady
sings
no no no no no no no we're never
fighting
absolutely
yes it's not over no yes no it's not
over yet
for dukkhan victory could be the
beginning of something really special
for khalil
well winning the
the competition
would definitely change my life
and if rosina wins tonight it'll be an
outstanding achievement for 63 year old
zita
to win the competition for us it will be
honor and
we're going to be over the moon to win
it
what did the diners make of the
brigade's dessert
it was beautiful lots of cinnamon
perfect
massive
enough to fill me for two
i thought it was a good season odds
there nicely spiced lots of cinnamon
really good nicer flavor to that
right dessert
but cena's the secret behind this
dessert
is the cooking the apples to begin with
that's delicious
not overcooked not undercooked and just
really nice and moist it doesn't stick
to the root of your mouth beautifully
done
dukin
nice
lovely color on the apples
nice and fragrant with the orange
running through and a really nice
generous canonization on the apples with
the honey delicious between the two of
them it's a tough call because they both
taste delicious it is my recipe however
i think the slight edge goes to duken
because they've got that real nice
flavor in the apples
with the last semi-final place up for
grabs the fate of the brigades is in the
hands of the diners right jb results
please
duken
i'm going to start with you
now the number of customers that are
happy to pay
for your desserts out of 25
is
that
is amazing 23 out of 25 well done
really well done
great job
that is fantastic well done that is a
very high score pretty good well done
right retzina that means you need four
or more
out of 25 for your dessert to win
tonight but that's not the only target
because
only the top six
the top highest scoring restaurants on
the leaderboard go through to the
semi-final
so to get in to the top six
you need to get 15 out of 25 or more
that's how tight it is
very tight okay the number
of customers
that are happy to pay for dessert
out of 25
bearing in mind
what's at stake
is
[Music]
17 out of 25. well done
[Applause]
that is amazing
congratulations
[Applause]
well done what an amazing night yeah
really seriously well done
i'm going to put it right in the front
of the
restaurant so everybody is coming and
they will see how proud i am
so rosina clinched the final spot in the
semi-finals
they'll be joining my best indian
chinese thai argentinian and british
restaurants
you